[Música]
Saludos y bienvenidos a France 24 y
radio Francis internacional nuestro
invitado de hoy es el expresidente de
Francia françois en esta entrevista me
acompaña
de rfi Saludos Señor Presidente buenos
días hace exactamente 10 años han
suaveland usted tomó la decisión de
involucrar militarmente a Francia malí
para frenar el avance de los grupos
yihadistas hace unos meses los soldados
franceses se retiraron a petición de las
autoridades de Malik en un país donde
los yihadistas han ganado terreno
usted suele decir que no se arrepiente
de la decisión que tomó en enero de 2013
pero francamente 10 años después no fue
un fracaso no
primero la decisión que tomé el nombre
de Francia en enero de 2013 no la tomé
porque Francia tuviera intereses en Mali
a tierra de
la tomé porque el presidente interino de
Mali En aquel momento y todos los jefes
de estado africanos nos pidieron incluso
nos imploraron
que actuaremos para hacer retroceder una
ofensiva yihadista que sin duda iba a
llegar a bamaco
Entonces si Francia y en ese momento yo
todavía era presidente permaneció en
Mali fue siempre por petición de las
autoridades y también de toda la
comunidad internacional
les recuerdo que la ONU también decidió
estar presente con una misión de
mantenimiento de la paz en Mali
Sí
si quisiéramos luchar contra el
yihadismo no fue Simplemente porque era
una amenaza para nosotros sino porque
afectaba a la población civil maliense y
más allá de Mali alzael a burkina a
níger y a otros lugares
por lo tanto para nosotros era un deber
ser solidarios Sí pero los yihadistas
ganaron terreno
desde que no son retiramos yo ya no era
presidente en ese momento
desde que las fuerzas francesas y otros
contingentes se retiraron los yihadistas
aprovecharon esa oportunidad para actuar
les ocasionamos pérdidas muy importantes
en particular a nivel de sus líderes
Pero en cuanto las fuerzas francesas se
retiraron los yihadistas que habían
mantenido sus posiciones las ampliaron
aún más y se desplegaron en otras zonas
por eso Francia sólo puede estar
presente si se le pide que lo esté
eso es lo que siempre he pensado no se
atenta contra la soberanía de un país
cuando ese país pide la presencia de
Francia
también les recuerdo lo que dije cuando
fui a bamaco
cuando tumbuctú había sido liberada y el
norte de Mali había recuperado una
relativa tranquilidad
dije que era un deber ser solidarios
porque no había olvidado lo que los
africanos hicieron durante las dos
guerras mundiales para ayudar a Francia
una película reciente recuerda esa
movilización
por lo tanto las fuerzas francesas
acudieron a mal y también para saldar
nuestra deuda con Mali así como con los
países africanos
hubo pérdidas claro que también hubo
poblaciones que siguieron siendo
martirizadas pero también hubo pérdidas
del lado francés hubo 59 soldados
59 soldados que sacrificaron sus vidas
porque yo decidí intervenir en Mali y
así esos soldados no murieron en vano
murieron porque estaban en una misión
para luchar contra grupos que oprimían a
la población
no fueron buscando ningún interés
económico ni por intereses mineros ni
para explotar los recursos de mal y
burkina faso o níger Buki
No hubo nada cambio ni ventajas
comerciales ni peticiones de concesiones
De infraestructura nada no hubo
compensaciones porque no había necesidad
de compensaciones porque estábamos
Unidos éramos solidarios y éramos amigos
en sus memorias publicadas en 2018 usted
dice que el Estado Mayor le advirtió que
una tropa yihadista podría llegar a la
capital abamaco a tres o cuatro días tal
vez menos hay quienes creen que no hubo
tal amenaza que usted la sobredimensionó
para vender entre comillas la operación
cerbal a la opinión pública Así que una
pregunta sencilla tenía pruebas
irrefutables ya sea por inteligencia
humana o técnica de que efectivamente
los yihadistas iban a atacar a bamaco sí
teníamos cierta información
Clara precisa
que indicaba que un grupo de vehículos
conducidos por yihadistas se dirigían a
bamaco
puede que se hubiera detenido por el
camino no lo sabemos pero iban hacia
abajo
no Solo lo decía Francia basándose en su
propia información todavía lo recuerdo
ya que usted me lo trae a la memoria
el presidente interino de Mali me decía
por teléfono que fuéramos porque mañana
o pasado mañana sería demasiado tarde
tenía el teléfono al presidente de la
unión africana que me decía que ellos
también tenían toda la información de
que los yihadistas se habían equipado
con vehículos que a menudo fueron
tomados del conflicto chadiano y sobre
todo del conflicto libio y que estaban
llegando y que tenían el equipo
necesario para controlar la ciudad
más tarde me pregunté si era posible que
unos cientos de yihadistas controlaran
una ciudad como bamaco
y
cuando tuve que enfrentarme a lo que
estaba ocurriendo en Irak
había caído bajo la presión de unas
decenas
cientos miles quizás de yihadistas
contra un ejército organizado como era
el ejército iraquí En aquel momento y me
dije que sí que sí era posible que esos
yihadistas no solo llegaran a bamaco
sino que controlarán la capital de Mali
Durante cuánto tiempo no lo sabemos pero
hubieran querido hacerlo y lo habrían
hecho por eso no exageré nada y fueron
los propios malienses quienes en ese
entonces por medio de sus autoridades me
pidieron que actuara porque estaban bajo
amenaza justo después de la reconquista
del norte de la operación herbal usted
fue a principios de febrero luego
abamaco y dijo esta frase que aún es
famosa
he vivido sin duda el día más importante
de mi vida política
no se dejó llevar por la victoria
militar
y diez años después dada la situación en
Mali y elsael en general no se
arrepiente de haber dicho esas palabras
no Porque eran palabras que sentía no
porque supiéramos que habíamos obtenido
una victoria militar sino porque
las mujeres se cubrían con la bandera
francesa enormes multitudes en timbuctú
y bamaco Simplemente nos pedían que nos
quedáramos para expresarnos su gratitud
estamos viendo estas imágenes que aún
tengo en mi mente y que están mostrando
había un reconocimiento hacia lo que
Francia estaba haciendo después vi con
pesar el deterioro de ese vínculo ese
vínculo que estaba fundado sobre la
amistad el reconocimiento de las
poblaciones presentes en Mali y también
en Francia
muchos malienses están en nuestra
economía en nuestro país viven su vida
pacíficamente aquí
así que me entristece ver que la
situación se deterioró Por qué se
deterioró seguramente porque como lo
dije antes
el yihadismo seguía atacando y los
maldienses se preguntaban Si eso
acabaría algún día y porque a pesar de
la intervención de Francia o de la
misión de la ONU
de las fuerzas africanas que la apoyan
sigue habiendo exhalaciones sigue
habiendo sufri ya viendo actos de
barbarie probablemente también porque
una operación militar que dura diez años
da la impresión de que en algún momento
es demasiado tiempo buscamos algo más
que ayudar la impresión de que se está
ocupando el territorio en cierta forma
algo que siempre hemos negado y además
estaba la propaganda propaganda que se
apoderó de las redes sociales y que
transmitía la idea de que Francia venía
a dominar un país que buscaba humillarlo
controlarlo dominarlo lo que no era
absolutamente el caso
solo Miren la influencia que tiene el
grupo Wagner o las redes financiadas por
los rusos que consiguieron convencer a
una parte de la población de que ellos
los protegerían mejor que nosotros
creo que los neocolonialistas son ellos
precisamente los militares franceses se
retiraron de malí y llegaron los rusos
podrían los rusos triunfar donde los
franceses fracasaron en territorio
militar o su miedo de hace 10 años de
que los yihadistas volvieran a tomar
bamaco vuelve a ser una posibilidad
en primer lugar cuando fuimos a Mali
fuimos con nuestra propia bandera a
petición de las autoridades malienses
[Música]
y con el apoyo de todos los países de la
región
y también con la legitimidad que nos dio
la ONU
incluso la legitimidad que nos dio la
ONU
hoy el que va a Mali no es un país Rusia
no declaró estar presente con sus
propios ejércitos o sus propias tropas
es un grupo privado cuyo vínculo con el
kremlin es bien conocido es un grupo
privado que vive del dinero que recibe o
de lo que saquea de un territorio es un
grupo privado que no rinde cuentas ante
ningún organismo internacional
es un grupo privado que no sabemos cómo
se financia ni Quiénes son exactamente
los soldados que Lo componen
a menudo son ex convictos que están allí
por intereses que se asemejan a los que
llamamos o solíamos Llamar mercenarismo
Pero y si tienen éxito
la otra pregunta es la que usted plantea
están teniendo éxito hay menos atentados
menos ocupaciones menos acciones del
grupo yihadista
La respuesta es no es peor es peor
porque el yihadismo Sigue avanzando
golpea a las poblaciones civiles con
masacres que han sido constatadas por un
cierto número de observadores y atacan
también en el sur de Mali donde no
estaban presentes hasta ahora
por no hablar de lo que está ocurriendo
en el centro de Mali donde se están
reanudando los combates que a menudo
afectan como ya dije a la población
civil
con enfrentamientos étnicos que se han
reavivado Por eso creo que este grupo no
solo no tiene legalidad en su actuación
de acción
sino que no tiene ningún interés general
en estar ahí salvo intereses muy
particulares y no es un grupo eficaz en
la lucha contra el terrorismo
respeto a la soberanía de los países
como lo he dicho Francia solo fue a Mali
porque se le pidió que fuera se marchó
porque ya no se quería su presencia si
los malienses quieren tener relaciones
con un grupo privado eso es asunto suyo
con un estado que no sea Francia eso es
asunto suyo pero llegado el momento
tendrán que responder por eso
usted lanzó otra operación en África la
operación San jaris en la República
centroafricana en diciembre de 2013 tres
años después Francia retiró sus tropas
en contra de la voluntad del presidente
fastón archán que estaba amenazado por
grupos Rebeldes
una pregunta muy sencilla le sorprendió
que llamara a los rusos de Wagner
estaban preparados para la llegada de
los rusos a Baní
aquí se nos reprocha Exactamente lo
contrario nos preguntan por qué no nos
quedamos más tiempo precisamente porque
consideramos que al estar desplegados en
Mali
al estar listos para intervenir en una
zona más amplia en el sael además de los
compromisos que teníamos en medio
oriente aunque no sean las mismas tropas
las que llevan a cabo estas operaciones
había un límite casi físico no hablo de
un límite político por lo que quisimos
que una misión de paz de la ONU la
minúsca tomara el relevo luego Lee y
apoyara al presidente electo de la
república centroafricana para garantizar
la reconciliación y la estabilidad en el
país
Aquí también hubo un llamado a otros no
los vio venir era mi pregunta
lo vimos venir Sin comprender que en
realidad se trataba más que de un apoyo
militar de un saqueo de los recursos del
país
vegetación
vemos que las minas de diamantes les
interesan a varios grupos privados y
también ahí hay flujos que se pierden
menos
en este caso también les corresponde a
las autoridades centroafricanas decidir
depende de ellos saber que quieren para
su futuro me parece bastante lamentable
que un grupo como Wagner se haya
instalado así la presencia de Francia lo
sabría disuadido no estoy seguro y luego
echad tras la muerte en combate de Iris
David hace casi dos años Emmanuel macun
viajó a yamena Para apoyar la transición
liderada por el hijo del fallecido magma
débil pero 18 meses después las
manifestaciones contra su deseo de
permanecer en el poder fueron reprimidas
violentamente dejando al menos 50
muertos el 20 de octubre Francia solo
reaccionó moderadamente y sin embargo
París ha condenado con firmeza los
golpes de estado que han tenido lugar en
Mali burkina faso y Guinea conacri No
hay demasiada indulgencia por parte de
Francia hacia el régimen sadiano también
en este caso como presidente de la
república tuve una relación muy estrecha
con el presidente David Pues el
presidente devi había actuado
activamente justo en el momento
en que había que expulsar a los
yihadistas del norte de Mali
por eso sé cuánto le debemos al chat y a
los sacrificios de esos soldados además
chat siempre ha aceptado participar en
nuestras operaciones internacionales
recuerdo lo que hicimos contra un grupo
terrorista que operaba en el lago Chad y
que por desgracia sigue operando
luego cuando el presidente devi murió
yo ya no estaba en el poder
no fue un verdadero golpe de estado lo
que sucedió fue Más bien una sucesión
militar con la idea de que dicha
transición duraría poco tiempo
y que el hijo del presidente débil no
sería candidato a su propia sucesión
Y actualmente ocurrió todo lo contrario
no solo se incumplieron los compromisos
adquiridos
sino que hubo una represión
extremadamente severa y los opositores
fueron encarcelados tengo la misma
actitud cada vez que hay un golpe de
estado cada vez que hay ataques a la
libertad opositores encarcelados condeno
esas decisiones
y cree que su sucesor no fue lo bastante
firme
creo que es consciente de que tenemos
una base en chat de que chat en esta
cooperación contra el yihadismo
Pero eso no es razón lo digo aquí para
que seamos tolerantes con los gravísimos
ataques a las libertades a los derechos
humanos y a los opositores de este
régimen
Gracias señor presidente por concedernos
esta entrevista y gracias a ustedes por
seguirnos en nuestros dos canales 24 y
rfi
[Música]